hey what's up my name's samuel leeds i'm
a property investor
and there's no one that's doing as many
property deals that i'm doing
who's putting out as much content on
youtube for free
as i am doing so i decided on this video
to do a q a session
where you can literally ask me anything
anything you want about business
property anything personal it doesn't
matter
comment your question below and i am
going to be answering
your question on my next q a video on
sunday at 7 pm
so comment below right now and i'm going
to answer some questions from last week
and while i'm answering some questions
maybe i'm asking i'm answering a
question and
you get an offshoot of a question in
which case just comment your question
below
the more questions the better because it
gives me more content
next week so i'm gonna look at what
we've had last week get commenting right
now also don't forget do me a massive
favor
subscribe to the channel and just turn
on the notification bell otherwise
i might answer your question but you
never knew i answered it what a shame
that would be what a pity
so turn on the notification bell
subscribe and also do me a favor if you
appreciate the content that i keep
putting out
smash the like button that would be
amazing go and hit like so what we got
so we've got um
sm says i've heard surveyors for lenders
are not coming out to see properties and
only do
basic desktop valuations due to the
pandemic
i'm concerned that this will lead to an
undervaluation of my brr project
please could you advise ps you're
awesome
thank you so much sm so i don't know
where you've heard that from but that's
not really entirely true
so valuers are going out to the
properties
and they are valuing them like all the
time i've got
several valuations on some of my
properties in the last few weeks
so they are they might be doing desktop
valuations if they don't deem it
necessary
to view the property so for for instance
if the if it was a
remortgage on a property and they know
the value
they don't need to go and see it
nothing's majorly changed or anything
that then they might just say we don't
need to come out
this is the new value and they'll tell
you the value
um and there might be some lenders that
are doing that more so than other
lenders
but lenders are still valuing so i
wouldn't worry about getting down by you
just speak to what just speak to a good
mortgage advisor
and just say hey look here's what i'm
doing but lenders i can confirm
are going to properties and i'll value
them and i confirm that based on my
experience of it happening
just the last few weeks hope that helps
ss says as it is difficult and time
consuming to find below market value
deals
in which you would adopt the brr
strategy
is it possible to successfully implement
brr when buying
at market value and driving value up or
is this too risky are you chances of
pulling most of your money out a low
if you can still do it what work would
you do to an average house to drive up
the value when brought at market value
okay ss so first things first
you're buying a property that you want
to do as a brr brr meaning buy
refurbish refinance rent
you're going to want to buy that house
as cheap as possible you're going to get
it really cheap now in terms of market
value
it doesn't matter too much about what
the what matters more than anything
is what the refurb cost is going to be
and what the end value is going to be
you know you want to get as cheap as you
can when you buy it so you need to be
finding properties that have got
problems with them
so you're asking me does it need to be
below market value well technically it
doesn't
it might be the market value i bought a
property last year
which was a property with some terrible
tenants the tenants couldn't get evicted
no one wanted the property it was a bit
shabby the tenants were smoking in there
and they weren't leaving the property
now i knew
that i would be able to solve that
problem i just knew i would
because i've got very a lot of
experience with dealing with people and
dealing with tenants
and i i thought you know what i've got
the right legal team
and on the legal team i've also i know
for instance i know that you can
bribe tenants out of a property if
there's a tenant in the property it's
not paying any rent and they're being a
pain
like if you give them if you give them a
thousand pounds look man
i'll give you a thousand pounds just
clear they'll usually go
okay so but that property because of the
bad tenants and the smoking and the
and the refusing to move that no one
wanted to buy it
the seller was really motivated to sell
it oh my gosh
if the tenant wasn't in there and it was
in decent condition
it might be worth 180 000 pounds
but as it happens they were selling it
they were paid to sell it for 125 grand
now only needed about 10 grand spending
on it but because of the tenant and
this now what was the current true
market value
well ultimately a house is only prepared
is only worth what someone's prepared to
pay for it
no one was prepared to pay anywhere near
180 for it
because of the situation and the
circumstances i bought it for one two
two
spent about 11 grand doing it up about
1500 quid sorting out the tenants and
getting rid of them
and then push the value up to about 185
good deal yes in the midlands
great deal so so you know you just need
to think
how can i find a property that's got a
problem
and then how much is it going to cost me
to fix that problem
and how much value is it going to add to
the property and every time you spend a
pound
you need to be adding three pounds worth
of value so
i hope that helps keep up the good work
my friend and um
let me know how you get on my zafa ali
i want to get into rent to rent hmos but
have very little money
is it possible to get a property that's
already fully furnished by a landlord so
i don't have to fork out much money
and i can just start earning money from
day one i realize that the rent might be
a little
bit higher to compensate for this
additional help from the landlord great
videos by the way
yeah you can do that 100 the only thing
i'll say is if you've got no money
and your skin and you haven't even got
the money to get furniture
don't forget when you take on a
rent-a-rent you're committing to pay the
landlord a fixed certain amount each
month so you better be damn
sure that you can fill the house up and
and then you've got enough money to not
only pay the landlord but also to have
some money for yourself
yeah you can do that you can do whatever
you want
an agreement with a landlord on a rental
rent
is a blank piece of paper you can
arrange whatever agreement you want
geez you could tell the landlord that
you also want him to come around your
house every sunday and run around the
house
i mean you can say whatever you want in
the contract so if you say you want the
landlord to put the furniture in
yeah you can say that question is will
they agree
that's another story that depends on
your skills and how
how persuasive you can be with your
offer and how you can emphasize and
communicate and articulate
how much value you're bringing and
whether you can find a landlord that's
got a bit of pain you know it's like i
don't want to deal with this house
anymore you want you need to be able to
know how to do that but
100 you can do it caramel papi
will samuel leeds make a group to go and
hunt down the samuel lee's haters
oh goodness and um and tyrone saxton
responded
i'll happily take the lead um i have no
intentions
i can i can confirm i have no intentions
of setting up a group that that hunts
down the samuel leads haters
um no not not at all uh if you want to
hunt them down
you'd be my guest i have no intention
all right russell petrae
how on earth do you make someone
financially free in a week when
solicitors take
four months usually and still waiting
after buying and selling a property in
one day
even the estate agents are wondering why
taking so long
okay russell thank you for your question
so it sounds to me like
two things going on number one you're
frustrated with how long
your properties are taking you to
complete number two you're asking me
how can i make someone financially free
in a week you know it takes ages
to complete on a house um so i'm going
to answer your question in two parts
firstly
i'm going to answer your question in
terms of you having a problem with
getting this property to go over the
line um it is normal to take four months
it does take time everything takes a
long time in property
everything does i've had properties that
have taken a year
to complete i've had my offer accepted
it's been 12 months later before i've
completed
so it is annoying it can be quick it can
happen in a few weeks
can be a few months in some cases can be
more than that so i would just say you
need to be really patient
and have multiple deals going on at the
same time if you've just got one deal
and you wait in and you wait in and you
look
in and it's not going through you get
frustrated if you've got
six or seven deals this one goes through
oh good and this one and
you don't worry about this one that's
taking a while so you know fill your
pipeline and be patient
um and make sure you've got good
solicitors as well but even good
solicitors
sometimes there are it just takes time
in terms of how do i make someone
financially free in a week um
the deals that we're getting on these
financial freedom challenges
the complete if we're buying a property
that's
never going to happen in a week the
financial freedom part
is and and really the financial freedom
challenges listen the reality is
that after a week it's not like oh
they're financially free they can line a
beach forever that no
what it is is they're set up in their
property journey for financial freedom
meaning they've got multiple properties
giving them an income and rent to rents
i mean you can get the keys in a day
with the rent to rent
some of the financial freedom challenges
that we've done in fact we've looked at
property reviewed it
and then within 48 hours call it
within 48 hours without the keys
and then within another few days
we've had tenants in there it can happen
very very quick because you're not
buying the property
you're controlling it and the difference
is you're using a templated agreement
you're using your rent to rent contract
rather than having to actually
buy a property and do searches and
surveys and valuations and get your
mortgage lender
that's what takes time um financial
freedom challenge we're doing like rent
to rent
deal sourcing getting quick money quick
deals quick that's what we're doing but
building the foundation
ready for then the person that does it
to go and stop building
their empire which will be slower you
know you don't get rich quick you don't
get
wealthy quick what you can do is you can
get results quick
um okay gonzalez i'm 19 and go to union
oxford i was thinking of doing
rent-to-serviced accommodation however
with all this going on right now
i'm not sure it's the best time to start
i might wait until after summer
or even 2022. my question is should i go
with rent to service accommodation or
switch to another strategy such as buy
to let
my dad is willing to fund the investment
maybe i could move into one room
would i need a special license contract
okay gonzalo you're in a great position
you're young you're 19
your dad's prepared to fund you on the
first investment you need to get
educated my friend
you need to come down to the property
investors crash course because honestly
if if i were you your dad's offered to
invest
in your business which is great but you
need to now prove yourself and you need
to
become investable you know invest in
yourself
and then more people will want to invest
in you um
in terms of rent to service
accommodation and buy to like you need
to know what you do you need to put a
game plan together i mean ranked service
accommodation
you think it's a terrible time i think
it's a fabulous time for many many
reasons number one because landlords are
really motivated because the tenant
eviction bans
you're doing rented service
accommodation there is no tenants
tenant eviction ban doesn't exist
because you
are paying the landlord but you have a
business to business
relationship so you don't have rights as
a tenant so the landlord likes that
but then you are renting the property
out of service accommodation
which is not tenants they're guests so
they have no rights
and if you can buy in the right area not
buy but if you can control a property in
the right area
service accommodation is very profitable
right now and as lockdown
eases off it's gonna get more and more
profitable so now is a freaking
brilliant time
if you know what you're doing but you
need to become investable and get smart
on the house brother gonzalez on the
house
free on me come and spend 12 hours with
me
at the property investors crash course
it's free i'll leave a link in the
description get booked on
there's a one pound um booking fee just
to check you're a real person
but uh get down to that okay um lucifer
says hi samuel i'm struggling to get a
mortgage due to my work as my
seasonal and travel a lot i want to buy
my parents house
and when they decide to move i have an
idea of a way to buy it but not sure if
it's legal or even doable
any advice has been muchly appreciated
my parents would gift me the house
230 grand with no mortgage after six
months i'll apply for buy to let
mortgage against the house
which would give me the cash to gift to
my parents
and then i could rent out the house to
pay the mortgage if my research is
correct they wouldn't need to pay
capital gains tax on gifting their
residents
i think you know what i think
that's not as easy as you think
because if you want to if you've if
they've got a property they can't just
you can't gift someone a house like that
you can't just say oh i've got a house
with no mortgage
there you go you can have it you can't
do that unfortunately you can you will
have to pay capital gains tax you're
also gonna have to pay stamp duty
tax it's the tax implications which
could potentially hurt you i've i know
this because i've got a lot of
properties in my personal name
i love them i haven't even got mortgages
on them okay because before i got
retrained
in 2018 i paid off loads of mortgages
yes sure i've refinanced a few
now but i when the tax changes hit i was
thinking
2017 i'm like is there going to be a
reverse is section 24 really gonna
happen
and when it really did happen you know
around about 2019 i was like man
2019 2020 i'm like man i need to move my
houses over to a company
to my company i'll gift my houses to my
company but i couldn't do it
it just wasn't it wasn't happening it
was so unviable
it did it it didn't make sense for me to
do it so i just kept them all in my
personal name
and i would i think you need to go and
speak to an accountant on this and just
work out exactly what the best plan is
to do
you know i'm not saying don't do
anything i'm just saying
it might not be as straightforward as
you think but i wish you all the best
lucifer
all right glam azone is it worth buying
a property with a 66 year lease
remaining
say purchase prices 80 grand and
potential rent income 600
a month i wouldn't buy it with a 66 year
lease no because
if it's got if it's a leasehold property
it needs it needs to outlive me and i
don't think 66 years is going to outlive
me
um maybe we'll we'll find out but listen
if he's got a 66 year lease
that means you don't own the land you
just own the property but when the lease
runs out what are you gonna do
if you if you've got a piece of land
that you don't own and you're leasing it
when that lease runs out the property is
not worth anything potentially
so even if it's an 80 grand house and
the rent is 600 pound a month
geez you can find better deals i don't
know the property so
i'd have to look at the property but i'd
be careful all right last question
okay by the way please do comment your
questions below right now and i'll
answer them next week
craig stone hi samuel i have two bites
and two rent to hmos
one refurbished and ready the other
should be ready at the end of the month
hey craig well done my friend good job
my question is a good thing to outsource
the tenant find and tenant management
within rent to hmo
um the numbers still work but i'm not
sure if this is a thing with rent to
rent
i can then focus on the bits i enjoy
like getting the property ready etc what
do you think i've enjoyed
the management side i've never enjoyed
the management side sorry
if you do think it's a good idea any
recommendations for hmm managers in
liverpool my strategy is to build the
rent to rent business to enough cash
flow and then buy properties
i also work two jobs at the same time
thanks
um great 100 i would i would um
outsource the management side of things
like any business you shouldn't be
managing the properties you've done it a
bit you've got some experience
if it makes sense even if it's to rent
to rent you don't you don't need you
don't need to do it yourself even if it
is a rental rent
you can make anything passive i've got
students that have deal sourcing
companies
that package and sell deals it's passive
because they have members of staff doing
it
so in liverpool any human management
companies i recommend yep
i would recommend i think they're called
now rooms now rooms in liverpool a guy
called brett
runs it great company great people i
like them
a lot so i could recommend them give
them a call
guys thank you so much my name is samuel
leeds i hope you found this video
helpful
comment below smash the like button
subscribe and i look forward to seeing
you
in the next video
[Music]